[Music]
let me tell you something
a driver on picnic car
car pick to drive some mystical bond
between man and machines of mystical mom
between man
[Music]
who are you do you speak told her you
[Music]
what's your name
[Applause]
you've got people out they will need you
[Music]
this is why you're here be
I know Pete music can help you say what
you're feeling try this hey excuse me
need some help no I'm good
let me take a look you know anything
about cars so what did you say you do
well that's a secret identified is that
well because if I told you you probably
wouldn't want to see me again who said I
was gonna see you again
would you well let's take this place say
it was a bank and instead of that
counter up there that was really a
tellers window and you just walk in real
calm so you walk right up look her in
the eye and you say ma'am this is a
robbery and you show her the gun like
this and you say but we want you to get
hurt cuz I like you I like you a lot so
don't go breaking my heart now okay
you're not serious
[Music]
excuse me I'd like to open up an account
well great what type of account do you
have in not this kind this kind he said
he was armed he had a gun you saw well
he was also sort of a gentleman he was
very polite he seemed like a nice enough
fella look at that is he smile
five states I need three robberies in
two years you think you can catch him
myself
let's hope I get the chance spend this
whole life locked up except for the
times that he broke out somebody should
have told me well you find something you
love exactly where I'm supposed to be
you're never exactly where you're
supposed to be are you now whatever I
closed the door I think this is the last
time I'll ever have a chance to do
whatever that thing was you know what I
do when the door closes
but you about the window is a gamble
baby love it as much the same wherever
sat down on the moors I said surely
there's an easier way to make a living
Danny look do and I said I'm not talking
about making a living I'm just talking
about livin
[Music]
do you know what my job description is
I'm in acquisitions and look up and I
catch what falls out of the sky
what's up
tell me about the mission did you see
anything unusual it's above our bakery
I get a cookie now look I get it
something went down in Mexico nobody
wants any witnesses we need to know if
you can you map owes a threat
we're Rangers it Baxley if your mom's
vagina were a video game would be rated
E for Everyone
there's an opposing the three kind of
the [ __ ] point
[Music]
predators just don't sit around making
hats out of rib cages the conquered
space but that's not what's on the
horizon should I be worried
Riley I think you know what is on the
ship the ultimate predators
we may die
we're still here
so come and get us [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what has happened in the world that
normal now passes as excellence when did
we lower our standards yes we are living
in an environment where people are blind
what you don't see you don't know
out of sight
something happened to tie something bad
our husbands aren't coming back
Ronald
[Music]
there's no a lot of money and now people
want it from us
now the best thing we have going for is
is being who we are why because no one
thinks we have the balls to pull this
off
are we from this world that's it down on
your knees
but this whole thing goes wrong
I want my kids to know that I didn't
just sit there and take it
I did something in this city
read which is so
let's hope so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi oh yeah gotta go if you want me to
drive you we gotta go no I want personal
chauffeur going works okay seriously dad
walking would have been fine
breaking news spider-man saves the day
against spider-man this guy swings in
once the day's zip zap zop dancing
gosh don't cops run red lights oh you're
some dude but uh not your dad in your
universe there's only one spider-man but
there's another universe it looks it
sounds like yours but it's not my name
is Miles Morales
thank you you like me
I knew my dad would come around his time
I know it's complicated
wanna know what happened to you I can
teach you to be spider-man hmm I love
this burger so delicious one of the best
burgers I've ever had
you have money right I'm not very liquid
right now I think you're gonna be a bad
teacher how am I supposed to save the
whole world you can't think about saving
the world you have to think about saving
one person one thing I know for sure
don't do it like me do it like you
[Applause]
[Music]
I see the spark in you it's amazing pair
drop whatever you choose to do with it
you'll be great
I love you boys I know that you gotta
say I love you dad I love you gotta copy
when did you teach me that I didn't it's
a little joke the team-building hey guys
okay who are you I'm Gwen Stacy how much
party people are there same as a
comic-con what's wrong
[Music]
there were dragons when I was a boy
where they went only a few know our
story changed the world forever
we did it
the world's first dragon Viking utopia
Julie don't be a maybe mine's lace
Claire did it more oh Santa honey hey
bud wait up
he's not the only one she's a light fury
you oh sorry
did he just disappear
[Music]
Wow
it's a hidden dragon worth
dude let's go introduce yourself has a
girlfriend I've hunted every Night Fury
except yours
hand him over I will never give him up
then I will destroy everything you love
we are no longer safe here we all have
to disappear completely off the map we
have to fight for their freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
you don't nothing without your dragon
[Music]
show them what you got but
[Music]
save him
if you and me buddy always
[Music]
you got this yummy in the ring you got
rules I'd say you got nothing
life history with all these cheap shots
people like me living past you got
people that you need you know you got
everything to loose
this guy's got nothing in loose ain't
got a choice that's to say that your
father said and he died right here in my
hands this to me this guy is dangerous
but you don't think I can beat
I was afraid I couldn't live up to these
expectations that my DNA you don't think
you got your validation
enjoy yourself
I want to rewrite history don't pretend
this is about your father
[Music]
it may not seem like you now but this is
more than just fight
is that my DNA testing one two three
we're on we're here to investigate a
patient that killed three innocent
teenagers on a Halloween in 1978 he was
shot by his own psychiatrist and taken
into custody that night and spent the
last 40 years in captivity
hello Michael I have something you might
like to see
everyone in my family like turns into a
nutcase this time of year yeah I mean
your grandmother is Laurie Strode she
was almost a murdered wasn't it her
brother converted all those babysitters
yeah it was not her brother
that's the magnet people made up do you
know that I pray every night that he
would escape hey Belle did you do that
for so I can kill him the bus crashed
what bus crash Michael escaped
excuse me somebody's in here it's waited
for this night who's waited for me
I waited for him
you don't believe in the boogeyman
my god
you should can close the closet door it
is game night I got a new laptop soon
you there's a cyber cafe that I've been
working out and this computer was
sitting the lost-and-found for the last
three or four weeks hang on he stole
someone's computer and it's stealing
yeah up I found this folder it was
hidden and it automatically connects you
to this thing dude this is dark web with
dark web
probably the internet but no one can
track you solve out drugs illegal IDs
seem an assassination for hire hey you
got the darknet it's mostly about the
bad guys and just computer it's got
videos on the right check this out
I really think you should stop I think
that is real guys that's what they're
trading what all those videos we have to
do something
is that wait guys hold up where's Lex oh
the ones you buy the videos the ones who
pick the girls please leave us alone
I can hear you are you see I can't see
you start turning buttock and put on
your church shoes little sister because
we're about to blast off what is it
you're trying to say we're going to the
Internet
[Music]
[Music]
this is the most beautiful miracle I've
ever seen
welcome to the search bar what can I
help you find today ah umbrella umbrage
Oh mommy the whole Noah's Ark no doubt
no it's from wrath
ergonomics Urban Outfitters oh cool I'm
pretty sure he's just trying to guess
what you're gonna say my auto failures
to touch aggressive today let me try
take me to a website that's super
intense and really nuts oh I don't have
one result come on characters
[Music]
hi ladies I'm a princess - what kind of
a princess are you huh
do you have magic hair no magic hands no
do animals talk to you know where you
fall is it no cursed no kidnapped or
enslave no are you guys okay call the
police
do people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up rapes the internet shouldn't be Ralph
Rex the Internet yes since he is
wreck-it Ralph uh yeah but break the
internet it's like a thing right it's
just wrecking it kind of sounds better
doesn't it you're not wrong
you